okay
how to put this into words
given that
so much of
the insight
that i experienced today was
experienced in the body it was
experienced
wordlessly it was
not a cognitive realization it was not a
form of cognitive
understanding it was
of what i think dancers and artists and
tantricas
would call
a kind of embodied insight a realization
that happens in your cells and in your
guts and in your heart and deep in the
recesses of your soul right there is a
there is a
a cognitive
way in which we can map the world there
is a cognitive schema that allows us
to make models of reality and use those
schematics to orient ourselves in the
world there's of course something to be
said
for this kind of
sober
and vigilant form of consciousness one
that is mapping the terrain and making
sure that you're prepared for a rainy
day but the problem with
cognitive oriented consciousness is that
even though it's great
at long-term thinking it's really bad
at uh
at
what you might call being present
cognition is constantly mapping out and
catastrophizing
future oriented kind of
uh scenarios and
before long we've left our body we're no
longer
in our body and this starts to
it starts to
become a heavy burden a kind of tax
in our psychological lives because we
become essentially disembodied beings
like and once we become
disembodied beings we lose touch with
ourselves we lose touch with our bodies
we lose touch with our archetypal nature
you know some people refer to this as
our masculinity or our
inner
our inner masculine you know the part of
us that is visceral and guttural and and
exists in the body the part of us that
is instinct the part of us that is lion
the part of us that is animal the kind
of
embodiment that we so marvel at when we
behold animals in natural habitats or
rock stars on stages there are feet
there are people who have freed the
brave reckless gods within them dancers
are another example gymnasts i mean
these are people who literally embody
right they are not just cognitively
oriented they're not just heads on
sticks but too many of us have become
heads on sticks including
myself and it has cost me profoundly i
think in my personal relationships
because it has made it very difficult
for me to commune with my lover
because there is a boundedness around me
an ego that is on patrol that is on
guard that has kept me safe that
disallows and disavows
um
responsibility and so and so
in other words there's a part of me that
goes
uh
enter into this at your own risk and
typically then what happens is i pull
back
from the brink of the annihilation of
the self and instead of dropping into my
body i collapse back into my head come
up with an excuse why this person isn't
right for me and continue on my own i uh
you know like i had on
sticks and um and today was different
because today i was listening to music
during this experience when i was
when i found myself
no longer there and by no longer there i
mean the part of me that mentates i was
no longer men tating the mind was not
any longer mapping
i was instead taken hold of by music
my eyes were closed and i was free
in a different way it was like whatever
question i ever had about how to dance
gave way instead to the realization that
dance is something that happens to you
if you let it
it's not about being in control but it's
about actually the exact opposite but it
becomes then a state of trust in the
body in the natural rhythms and cadences
and language and intelligence of the
body right to be in rhythm with
music simply means to be in tune and on
time right there is a rhythm to things
and you can become attuned to that
rhythm if you are in your
body there is this innate sensibility
and intelligence and it actually expands
one's world and expands one's
psychological life and it expands the
richness and the depth and breadth of
one's experience one becomes
temporarily shamanic and so it was
interesting because i am a man of
letters and i love words and i use words
to map
you know not just my everyday life but
also ineffable states but i can't make
the mistake of thinking that those
states can be mapped without first being
experienced without words in other words
even i need to learn to close my eyes
and just let go and close my mouth as
well and today in song i realized this
is what i need to bring into the bedroom
and into my interpersonal relationships
and into my love making i need to get
out of my head and it landed deeply
today as
a psycho physical adjustment
that i think now is about to just uh
unleash hopefully a set of changes in my
life and a realization that a path needs
to be adjusted and there's healing to be
done
and it's going to require courage
um
to let go of one's armor
so
bear with me
i'll report back